[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris sims texas longhorn
apologist pro football talk live co-host
how excited were you your longhorns were
gonna beat alabama how excited was it in
a home
it was it was awesome it really was it
was great watching it it was really it
was special the stadium looked amazing
right
mike i don't know dan call me crazy or
whatever but i'm like not even upset i'm
not
that was a victory to me i mean hey
we're like we're relevant again we're
actually might be good again i think
that was the encouraging thing i mean we
kind of looked the part you know steve
sarcasian i am a believer in him i know
he's one of the better offensive minds
in college football it just stunk that
quinn ewers got hurt i wanted to see
that cause he does have some special
attributes about how he throws the ball
i wish he'd cut his hair but damn he can
throw that football uh so that that it
really and to me was a win even though
it was a loss it was a win i think
overall for the program going forward
any doubts about arch manning coming in
there i know quinn ewers is there now
and he was the number one recruit in
america and he's going to lose his job
but
any concerns that arch comes in and he's
not able to live up to what texas fans
expect
well you know
i mean i've lived that a little bit i do
i mean there's there's that anywhere you
go when you have the last name manning
right there there is and then when you
put couple in the fact that yeah there's
a guy who queen of yours who you know we
saw on social media in high school and
and even here just a little bit to go oh
this dude can throw the football like
legit like has a big time arm it's an
nfl type arm for sure so that would be
my concern you know the other aspect of
that is it's the mannings and they don't
leave anything to chance so there's a
part of me that's also like you know
texas had to sign a contract like he has
to start by year two or we get control
of the school in the stadium and
whatever you know what i mean that's the
way the mannings are they're just very
they're like that so that's where i do
it but you're gonna have competition and
pressure wherever you go when you have
the manning family hey when i went to
texas i was the number one player in the
country the next year we brought in like
chance mock who i believe was the number
one quarterback in the country too and
it's just like oh crap gosh i'm gonna
have to compete here so you're gonna
have to deal with that when you go to a
major school like that
the difference between the quarterbacks
tonight and justin herbert and patrick
mahomes the one
the one thing herbert does better than
mahomes and the one thing that mahomes
does better than herbert great question
great question these are these for my
money are the you know two of the three
best quarterbacks in the game and you
you add in josh allen to that i think
that's you know you've seen my rankings
and we've talked about it in the spring
i think these are those are the three
best in the game um this is where i
would say there's a difference uh
herbert
in the pot i call him the machine when
the pocket's clean and he's sitting
there big soldier and he looks like a
machine because he's so big with the
square shoulders he hits the bullseye
almost every throw so he is to me better
in that environment than my homes and
you know we're talking about great
versus great here so it's not like it's
mahomes is weak in this category but i
would give herbert the credit of pocket
clean gotta hit the bullseye 15 yard in
cut 20 yard out wrap boom he's gonna hit
it every time mahomes i think has the
you know the vice versa advantage of
that when pocket's not clean or i gotta
fade away or float or throw a sidearm
ball at a 20-yard out route that's to me
he's maybe the most gifted guy we've
ever seen do that he's like an artist
that way so that would be the difference
there but we know that you know both of
these guys can pretty much do whatever
they want on the football field
what's josh allen do better than those
two quarterbacks
oh
he's a little bit of a mixture of both
where i'd go
he runs
he runs better for sure right i mean
he's a force of nature other than lamar
jackson i don't you know lamar jackson
and jalen hurts i don't know if there's
another force
better than josh allen as far as a
runner
but how did we miss josh allen he wasn't
a big time recruit in high school right
he wasn't you know a big time player at
wyoming i mean he was a curiosity there
yeah
when he lost his talent he didn't really
have a good final year there
but you still had teams that were kind
of fawning all over him
yeah his first year he didn't look good
what was your review of josh allen
coming into the nfl well you know my
review of him we discussed this a little
bit i thought he was the number one
quarterback
i'm letting you take a victory no i know
no i know i know i wasn't trying to be a
jerk i know i'm john stockton you can be
carl malone i'm just giving you a bounce
pass just make votes i'll hit that i'll
hit that 12 foot all day long
yeah but yes i i i love josh allen
coming out you know as as we have
discussed so many times in our history
and and being together is it's just it's
we we we look at wins and stats a little
too much and we lose the context of the
situation a little bit and that's to me
what happened with josh allen a little
one the talent jumped off the screen you
know you know the ability to run and do
all that the ability to throw the ball
really wherever he wants there was all
this talk about accuracy and i kept
going i don't really see an accuracy
problem i see a guy that sometimes
thinks he can fit the ball into every
window in the history of the world right
but there were so many plays where i'd
go oh yeah that was incomplete but damn
he fit it in between those three guys
and put it right where he wanted to
and there was it bounced off the
receiver's head or you know there was
just too much traffic in there and he
just dropped the ball let alone he was
playing up in wyoming where there was
crazy weather conditions and then i also
got into the fact of like the completion
percentage i went man did they ever give
the guy an easy throw or do anything and
i compared him to la that year with
baker mayfield and sam darnold who threw
like an average of like seven or eight
screens a game and i went well if he
threw seven or eight streams a game his
completion percentage would have been up
around 67 68 percent and maybe that
wouldn't have been a question let alone
to your point dan the support system
around them was crappy it didn't present
itself and then i think they kind of
gave him a green light a little bit to
like hey do whatever you want because we
can't win unless you make magic happen
and that kind of led into some bad
habits as well so that's what i saw um
but yeah like it came out again this
week a little bit i i know
that the seattle seahawks wanted to
trade russell wilson to the cleveland
browns because they wanted to take josh
allen with the number one pick the year
that the cleveland browns took baker
mayfield and then you know
josh hang an extremely smart guy too
that's the one thing i think gets a
little lost in translation because we
see a great talent and we just go oh
he's talented but anybody you talked to
his testing before the draft was off the
charts and all that stuff and of course
he's picking up offenses left and right
here in the nfl and uh he's almost a
combination of herbert in my homes in a
way dan to get back to that original
question like maybe not as good as the
sidearm stuff as my homes but just a
little below maybe not as good as the
machine like herbert in the pocket but
just a little below and then his ability
to run you know power football and
scramble i mean come on have we ever
seen a quarterback stiff arm a safety in
the nfl and throw him on the ground and
get a first down i mean that was insane
stuff what we saw you know in the opener
but i wonder if you go back and
revisionist history if you said seattle
was going to trade russell wilson to
cleveland yeah in his prime right for
the wyoming quarterback
yeah they would have gotten roughed up
now we look back now
and it's revisionist history
right i mean it's good that josh allen
didn't go to seattle the way pete
carroll wants to win he wouldn't have
been taking advantage of all the
attributes that josh allen has but
looking back
yes seattle made the right move
i think if they keeping russ
because josh allen was an unknown you
can look at all the towns sure like
davion clowney remember his pro day
i had people at the mothership frothing
slobbering all over i've never seen
something like this and i went
okay
he had one great play in college and
that was the bowl game against michigan
yeah slow down he doesn't have any lower
body strength
i i mean you had guys who were played
the game who were like teddy brewski
they're like i haven't seen anything
like this before we get caught up in
this
we do i mean he's had a nice career but
it's just i think we always want to be
the first to say you know we got to beat
everybody to the punch i i saw him
before it's like you have a favorite
band you know i saw
you too when they played in front of 22
people i saw dave matthews at a frat
party you know
so yes i don't know no i i know i think
your point is there i i get what your
point is i don't know either you're
right the fact that he got to buffalo
and mcdermott this is where i think it
is amazing and i talked about this with
josh allen in my long interview a little
bit before the season on my podcast and
stuff because that's one of the you know
we don't see defensive coaches a whole
lot just go hey offensive quarterback do
whatever the hell you want and we're
just going to go with you yeah and that
was special and you're right i don't
know if pete carroll would ever done
that i do think that the seattle
seahawks and pete carroll for a while
were looking to replicate what they did
originally with russell wilson get a
quarterback on a rookie contract right
and let's build the team around it
because i'm not all about the
quarterback in seattle here and let's
try to do it that way but it's hard to
do that to your point when you go well
russell was he's damn good and he's so
clutch and he helped us win a lot of
games after the legion and boom fell off
because he was so good so i hear you
there i i you know that that's a tough
one and i don't know if it would be the
same josh allen if he was up there in
seattle he's uh chris sims he uh works
for pro football talk live and it's the
show before ours on peacock uh explain
the chief's offense without tyreek hill
and
how it could be better than it was
i'm one that's kind of been i think it's
going to be better i've been kind of
saying that all off season we'll see i
mean that's a it's dicey i mean tyree
kill is special i know that there's no
question i think where i look at it is i
don't think
you know
i think the the offense by committee can
be a blessing really for the chief's
offense and for mahomes a little bit
there definitely was times last year
where he tries to force it to tyree kill
too much or makes decisions just based
off of that i also think that with tyree
kill and the fact that they always felt
like hey we gotta get him and kelsey the
football that you know and i've talked
to defensive coaches about this a little
bit you had a little feel for oh wait
tyrek's in the slot they're gonna kind
of run these plays oh wait tyreek's the
outside of three receivers they're gonna
kind of go to these plays and i think
where they have an advantage right now
is you just you don't know you can't
other than kelsey you can't really
figure out who's being used for what and
what's going on there and they got a lot
of guys that are very good at the
receiver position they got some tight
ends too to go along with kelsey where i
think they're gonna be able to play some
two and three tight end sets this year
and be annoying that way so uh and i
also think like the bills the chiefs are
a team on the mission they are they just
they look the part to me they look like
they're pissed off about losing the afc
championship game you know the andy reed
and beach have done a very good job of
kind of retooling that team on the fly
there uh but i think that's my kind of
you know sum up of the chief's offense
it's a little hard to tell how they're
going to attack you without tyree kill
now well it feels like we moved on from
the rams quickly
um
i know right i know yes it does like a
national tv loss or win
really amplifies the good or the bad but
what are your what are your bigger
concerns about the rams this season my
bigger concerns and and you know i
picked the rams to go to the playoffs
but i picked them to go as like a six
seed right and and
you know again it's hard to replicate
going back-to-back super bowls like we
talked about but my biggest thing is
you know that playing a tough division
they lost some real difference makers on
their football team you know obj von
miller darius williams
they lost some good role players too and
troy reader
right sebastian joseph day lost two
whitworth retired austin corbett got you
know traded to the the carolina panthers
so there's this new offensive line there
you know i don't know if jalen ramsey's
quite as good as he used to be i i still
i love me some jalen ramsey but i'm not
sure he's like the best corner in
football anymore or if he is there's a
lot of people competing with him there
so that's what scares me about the rams
a little bit stafford's elbow not being
there them not getting to practice you
know so i look at that and just go
i don't think there's dominant up front
on either side of the ball that's what
scares me i still still think they're
going to be a pain in the butt mcvay's a
hell of a coach but i don't see
like super bowl in the in the in the
globe this year or in the uh what do
they call that magic ball or whatever
for the rams uh the seahawks broncos
ending
you had a rookie head coach nathaniel
hackett who said here's our strategy we
wanted to get to the 46-yard line
which i don't know why
with russell wilson you go no we got to
get to the 46.
i don't think that that should be your
philosophy
and i said you got this is why you got
russ if i have drew lock i'll get to the
46 and we'll try to kick a field goal i
have russell wilson why the hell am i
spending 250 million dollars to go russ
thank you some nice parting gifts mr
mcmanus go out there and kick a field
goal yeah agreed on that point totally
and then to add to that like
i just
the line of demarcation was if we get to
this place
we can maybe win the game with like the
second longest field goal in the history
of football that that doesn't make sense
that process is flawed there bill
belichick didn't go to you know
nine super bowls and all that going well
if we just get to the place where i've
seen my kicker make it one time before
that's will be good right you get your
the process is we need to get to a place
to where i think my kicker can be four
for five right from that maybe maybe get
to the 41 for a 57 58 yard field goal so
that's where the first thing i just go i
don't buy it and then the second thing
is i think the play was called an
offensive play was called russell wilson
was in the huddle too long yeah and he
was giving a play the left guard was
looking back waiting for russell wilson
to lift his leg to call the snap there
was no drawing anybody offside they
weren't doing a snap count the whole
game they were lifting their leg you
couldn't hear anybody to draw any so
there's i think they're trying to cya
you know cover their own ass here a
little bit down the stretch a little um
and i think the fact that the play got
in late and things and then i think he
changed his mind a little bit and that's
unfortunate it was a rookie mistake
because it takes away from the broncos
offense looking about as good as this
looks since the peyton manning era and
the defense made great adjustments in
the second half the two fumbles at the
goal line certainly were a big changing
point in the game uh but yeah that
decision takes away from from a lot of
good stuff i think the broncos did there
in the football game and it's a it's a
great notice by you that russ was ready
to call play
absolutely absolutely no doubt about it
he was giving a signal and lining people
up that isn't i'm jumping offsides and
they were in the huddle for a
significant amount of time he wasn't
just going jump off don't jump offside
hard count don't jump offside heart
count and saying that for 20 seconds no
he was spitting out a play for everybody
so you know it's just yeah it was
mishandled there was there was problems
with them getting the play in all game
long hopefully they can fix that i
expect them to rebound in a big way
against the texans this week oh that's a
real stretch by you
i'm calling my shot dan
great to have you on bud thank you
thanks thank you guys chris sims pro
football talk live with uh mike florio
that precedes our show on peacock